Speaker 1: And finally today, again, a little
bit more about these hearings. But I'm sorry,
folks. It's the biggest news in the country right
now, FOX News. FOX News has, of course, after
they decided to not air the first hearing and
then lost a bunch of viewers to other networks,
decided they've got to start running them. And
they have been. And here's what's remarkable.
You have hosts on that network. That I finally
started to open their eyes and realize, Oh my God,
this looks bad. Neil CAVUTO has come out and
admitted this looks really bad for Donald Trump.
And Martha MACCALLUM this week. Said that it
was, quote, stunning. That there was such an
amazing lack of evidence to any of Donald Trump's
claims of voter fraud. Let me read the statement
that she said on the air on Fox News this week
It will be extremely useful in coming campaigns,
especially the presidential. When you look back
at what we have in terms of the Mike Pence part
of all of this. So it is a political discussion.
It is very compelling. And the lack of evidence
is the huge, stunning, clear moment here where
these people are saying, look, I supported you.
Please give me something to work with.
And it simply doesn't materialize.
Now, to be honest, Martha, if you actually
watched any other network other than your own,
you wouldn't be stunned by any of it. Like, that's
the funniest part of all the shows. Like, oh,
my God, this is stunning how there's no evidence.
No, no, it's not. It's not stunning to any of us
at all that have been paying attention to this,
because there's never been any evidence, even
when, by the way, Republicans have had
the opportunity to provide evidence,
they have failed to do it. I mean,
hell, Mike Lindell, CEO of Mypillow,
actually has another little cyber symposium
type thing coming up in a couple of weeks
where he says, This time I'm going to give you
all the evidence, all of it, every bit of it.
Oh, really? Just like you promised us last August.
Just like you promised us over the Thanksgiving
break. You're holding these cyber symposiums. You
swear up and down, you have all this evidence,
and then, gosh darn it, when it comes down to it,
you always just forget to give it to us. Wolf's
right. Rudy Giuliani, same thing. Claims to have
all this evidence. Heck, the dude even claims to
have the contents of Hunter Biden's laptop.
Or at least he claimed at one point he did.
Nothing. Nothing at all, huh? And Martha MACCALLUM
is stunned by this, that there is no evidence to
back any of this up. How are you even stunned.
Okay. Even if these people who claim to have had
it don't turn it over. How can you be stunned
when we have had recounts, we have had audits,
we have had signature verification. We have had
every possible thing to look into, every possible
election, and nothing materialized. None of
this is stunning. None of this is shocking.
All you had to do, Martha, which I'm glad you're
doing it now, would have been great if you'd done
it a year and a half ago. All you had to do was
open your eyes. Listen, that's all the time we
have for today. We have a wonderful members
bonus show coming up today. Lauren Boebert
got a lot of more trouble with her coming up. We
also have duel being banned by the FDA. But hey,
if you want more from me, Farron Cousins, find me
on YouTube. YouTube.com, slash the ring of Fire,
YouTube.com. Slash fair and balanced. I'm
on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram at Fair
and Balanced. Thank you so much for David for
letting me fill in bonus show coming up shortly
this The David Pakman Show.
Unidentified: Thank you for watching.